hey thanks a lot for the introduction
and actually I've I've had in my
academic or in my career I was not a
researcher at sap but I was actually an
engineer at sap so I've seen both sides
of Defense right so being really
involved in product engineering product
development and now I'm back in Academia
since already six years which is is a
lot
um today I'm talking about one of my
major lines of research in my lab that
I'm conducting and it's actually a joint
effort also with Google where I'm
currently a visiting faculty researcher
with a systems research group
but before I actually go into the deep
and the depth of my research which as me
as academic should do Let Me Maybe
quickly pitch what this is all about
maybe every one of you kind of has maybe
an idea what learned database systems
could be but maybe let me first set the
stage
so I've been working a long time in
database industry and what users really
want from databases is that databases
are fast right so if you submit a query
you don't want to wait for hours until
the result comes back but you want to
have easily your result instantly back
clearly depending on data size this is
not always possible but the desire is to
get results quick
however if you if you've worked with
databases you know that this is not true
right even a query that maybe has run
today in seconds might run tomorrow in
minutes and then you are kind of doomed
so the reality that you see in
performance of databases is actually not
the pictures you saw before but often uh
you drive your car your database into
some roads where the performance is
maybe not as you intended it to be
the good side is uh for a long time
there was a solution to that indeed in
database industry right so you could get
out of this road by asking the nice guy
who was called the database
administrator so in the 2000s
you had to ask the database
administrator here's my query here's my
database this is slow make it fast right
and you didn't have to take care about
anything and the DBA knew all the dirty
tricks of what indexes to create how to
set buffer pool sizes and so on and so
forth so this was a nice situation
because you could kind of offload your
problems to the DBA
but I'm unfortunately things are
changing today so if you look in the
database Market
we see that the situation is going
clearly towards Cloud this is nothing
new for you but maybe the interesting
observation here is that in the database
Market what that means is that the cloud
revenue is slowly taking over compared
to on-premise databases so in the
on-premise world you had your own
database admin for your own database in
the cloud things are changing you are
kind of Outsourcing your database to a
vendor you might kind of use database as
a service offers from Amazon Google
Microsoft or snowflake which provide
managed database as a service solutions
and you have to trust in in them that
they kind of
tune your database such that it provides
high performance for the queries you are
submitting but for them this is a huge
challenge they need to manage thousands
or even more of customer databases and
need to be able to provide high
performance for those databases for
various types of of data sets customers
come in or various types of queries
users submit
and therefore this manual approach of
optimizing your database individually
for every database the customer brings
and for every set of queries that the
customer brings does not scale at the
size of the cloud anymore so the
question is what to do here and this is
where actually my or the the the things
we are working on comes to stage where
we or where Academia and Industry are
currently thinking about a direction
which is called learn databases the
question is can they solve this problem
for building databases that kind of can
provide high performance for any type of
data data set that the user provides in
any type of queries the the user submit
so that 10 000 feed view for this learn
database direction is that a learned
databases look a bit like this so the
promise of a learn databases is that you
build a database once like a car and it
knows how to adjust to the situation it
is used in so like this is my son would
love this picture it's a idea of
Transformers not Transformers as machine
learning models it's just a car that
transforms into the most suitable thing
for the task it should do and thinking
of a database it would be a database
that optimally adjusts to the data and
queries you want to store in it and you
want to use for querying the data
now let me maybe Zoom a level deeper and
go into the direction of how these
learned database systems should work and
what the main idea is
so learn databases in a nutshell what is
the idea the main idea is that in a
learned database what we do is we
replace classical components such as a
database index or think of any other
component that is internal in a database
system that is used to run your queries
this is replaced by a machine learning
component the question is now why should
you do that sounds like a nice idea
machine learning is today everywhere why
why shouldn't we use machine learning in
databases but the idea here is that the
machine learning model replaces the
classical classical component like index
with a component that provides near
Optimal Performance for the type of data
you are storing so you can think of an
index that adjusts itself to the data
distribution you want to query and
therefore the index the Learned index
can provide high performance for any
type of data and any type of queries you
run on your table where in contrast in
reality in with the old world you had to
know which index to use and when indexes
actually make sense
and the second nice maybe I uh side
aspect of using machine learning to
replace database components is that you
can get rid of this manual engineering
and tuning of database components so in
the old world as I said you had to
manually decide which index to use you
maybe had to set certain parameters of
your index to make it fast and efficient
with machine learning the idea is that
we learn the parameters of indexes that
we learn an optimal index layout such
that it can provide high performance on
different data sets
now let me maybe explain a bit the idea
of an index in the Learned index maybe
just for those of you who are not that
much in database internals and don't
know what indexes maybe are used for to
give you an idea what maybe the first
solution was to bring let's say learn
components into database because indexes
was like the first work that kind of
went in this direction of learn database
components
so what is a classical classical index
in databases I'm not sure who of new you
know here B trees they just raise your
hands okay substantial amount but for
the others maybe let me quickly explain
in a very high level what uh what a what
the B3 index is so um think of you for
example here like you have a table a
customer table with where you store
customer data like customers with their
names H's and so on and you want to
search in your large table which might
have millions or billions of entries
only those customers that have a h14 so
what the index or what you can what the
index actually does it's like a lookup
function you can ask the index I'm
looking for customers of the h40 and the
index index kind of gives you a a
position where to look up these
customers in your table so you don't
need to scan through your millions and
billions of data rows in your table but
the index will tell you look at row 15
look at row 20 and there you find the
customer with h40. and people have been
devising manually indexes that provide
high performance on Modern Hardware so
database Engineers that develop database
systems have been really active in the
field of providing high performance
indexes but still indexes not always
provide good performance so it depends a
bit on what queries you have and what
types of data you store on your table
so there was a an initial paper in 2018
that suggested to replace classical
indexes by learned machine learning
models so the high level idea here is so
instead of having a b tree which
implements this lookup function you have
a machine learning model maybe a shallow
neural network that gets this input uh
the same search key and the output so
the prediction of the machine learning
model is the position in the table where
you should do the log the lookup and
this initial work has shown that neural
networks can learn really fast and slow
indexes meaning really fast and small
lookup functions that translate the
search key here the age of the customer
into position in the table
and here's just a short plot from the
initial paper that was from MIT
co-authored with Jeff Dean from Google
where they showed this trade-off let's
say in what let's say what the benefits
of learn indexes are and here they
compared learned indexes or the first
version that they developed for learn
indexes to classical beat trees and
other types of indexes that have been
developed in the database industry for
years
and what this blood shows there's a huge
potential so learned indexes in a
nutshell can provide performance that is
way faster than classical indexes at a
storage footprint that is way smaller
because they succinctly learn for the
given data distribution uh only the the
type of how how the data is distribution
they learn how the position or which
position to look up so they can easily
adjust their behavior to the data
distribution you are searching in
and maybe to go even a step further
indexes have not been the only example
so if you go to academic database
conferences of the last let's say two
years
you can pick any database component that
the database internally uses to run a
query be it a query Optimizer be the
query scheduler be it operators such as
a join between two tables and there has
there have been papers that have shown
that you can replace any of the database
components with a machine learning model
that provides better performance that
reduces storage footprint and so on so
the academic world has been really
active in this area and shown divide
applicability of learned components that
replace classical database components
so the question is why am I standing
here and what are maybe the pitfalls of
using these learned components and
therefore let me set the stage so how
learned components are realized today so
what I'm talking about now is the
initial directions of how people realize
learn components and then I come to a
bit more the advances in the last few
months years a half a year where the
where the field has been moving towards
to to solve the problems of the initial
directions
so let me explain you how the state of
the art of this initial Direction works
that I call learn database components
1.0
and here the pro the predominant
approach is that these models have been
learning by executing queries in a
database system and observing the
behavior and by observing the behavior
they could decide what is optimal what
is not optimal and then they've devised
the model that learns the optimal
behavior and therefore they are called
workload driven X or workload driven
learning because they need to run SQL
queries on a database to run to learn
index to learn a query Optimizer and so
on
let me explain this by a quick example
how this workload driven Learning Works
to make it really clear what what the
basic idea here is so let me take a very
simple database component so inside
every database there's one component
that needs to predict the query cost or
the query runtime of a query so given a
SQL query how long would this run on a
given database so on this database it
would run five seconds on another
database which maybe a small data it
would run 10 minutes and this carry
runtime prediction is important task
because databases internally use this
task for query scheduling to decide for
example when to run a query to which
parallelization degree to use and so on
so to use machine learning for this type
of task the basic idea might be clear so
the first thing is you need to run a
representative set of SQL queries on
your given database observe the runtime
of these queries so for for the
different queries you just monitor how
long they run and you then you train a
model that can map SQL queries to
runtime so the model would be a
prediction model that gets this input a
SQL query and that spits out at a time
in seconds or execution resources that
are needed to execute the query
and at inference time to use this model
what you would do if you get a new query
you would use this trained model just
feed the new query into the model and
the model would spit out a prediction a
runtime prediction that the query
scheduler can use and people have shown
that this approach is highly accurate
it's much more accurate than the
classical approaches database have been
using using because database use
typically very simple heuristics and
analytical models that are often not not
accurate enough so learning and this
type of workflow driven learning has
shown much benefits in terms of accuracy
however it's still highly unattractive
in practice and you might already know
why it's unattractive I've shown it here
it's you need to run queries to train
your model and in fact what you need to
run is 10th of South thousands of query
just to learn a single model so to learn
one runtime prediction model for one
database you need to First Run 10 000
queries which might take on its own
hours or days to run these 10 000
queries depending on the size of your
database and then you can train your
model and when your database changes
when you have updates on your database
or if you need to support a new database
so meaning a new set of tables with very
different data characteristics you need
to rerun these queries again so you need
to run again 10 000 queries and this is
comes at a high cost and if you think at
the size of a cloud provider that needs
to run a host thousands of databases 10
times 10 000 of queries and you need to
rerun these queries every time data
characteristics change in your database
then all in a sudden
machine learning or learn database
components don't don't look that
attractive anymore even though they are
highly accurate and they speed up
databases because they provide more
accurate predictions for runtime
estimates and so on it's not worth doing
it
so what we've been doing in research and
this is a line where my group has been
heavily active in is a direction called
learn databases 2.0 where we actually
want to avoid these high-end repeated
costs of training models that can
replace database components such as the
index or query Optimizer and so on
so our contribution are these is this
direction called learn databases 2.0
and for this I'd like to so we've been
mainly working on two directions I'd
like to present One Direction today
which is data driven learning I quickly
talk about a second Direction later on
but I don't go into detail here for the
data driven learning bear with me I will
go do one step in or deep dive into the
technical background about how this
direction works
so what is data driven learning on a
nutshell again and why is it better than
learning learn database components 1.0
the main idea is that when you want to
learn a model such the one that we've
seen before so instead of running
queries we have seen that we can solve
many database problems just by looking
at the data with without running any
query so meaning in the previous example
I've shown you need to run 10 000
queries to come up with a good query
runtime prediction model and we've shown
that for certain type of tasks you can
completely ignore queries you can just
use it and learn or realize a learn
database components for example index
without running queries you just need to
look at the data Distribution on its own
and this is enough to learn a model that
replaces a database index
and this is what I'm going to do a bit
deep dive in a minute so this direction
is promising because you can take your
data and you can train the model right
on without this High overhead of of
running 10 000 queries as I said before
the second direction is um something we
call zero shot learning for database
Management Systems so why do you need
this you might have seen it so the the
data driven learning is limited to tasks
that do not require any knowledge about
the workload so that are kind of query
agnostic and for those you can learn
models without without this High
overhead of workload or executing
workloads in a database but there are
some tasks like query scheduling runtime
estimation where you need to run or have
a notion at least what is the complexity
of a query if I would execute it and for
this we have devised this direction of
zero shot learning where the idea is
that you learn for example a runtime
prediction model on different
representative databases so we do some
kind of a pre-training of a model that
we need to do once and then we can use
this model out of the box for many new
unseen databases so whenever a customer
comes to a cloud provider and loads the
data into the in for example in data
based system we could use such a zero
shot model out of the box to do runtime
prediction for this new database without
any training so it's a bit like the what
you know from maybe language models that
are pre-trained on large text corpora
and then used on on new text that it
hasn't seen we do the same thing on
databases we train models on a variety
of different databases and then you can
use this model on an unseen database out
of the box and I mean I mean a model I
mean for example a model that replaces a
query scheduler or query Optimizer in a
database system
maybe five to ten minute deep dive into
this left Direction and I'm I'm setting
the stage for data driven learning to
that I hope that I can kind of take you
all with me because this is now going
into really into my into the into the
heart of my what my research group is
doing
so
let me for this explain a quick task
that databases need to solve day by day
so when a query like this comes into a
database system so this is a query that
joins three tables customer orders and
Order lines order lines are kind of the
products that the customers would buy
maybe in an online shop like Amazon and
this query wants to list all the orders
of customers that are from Europe that
were ordered in the online Channel and
that had a price lower than ten dollars
so what a database is doing when this
query comes in it needs to find
something that is called a query plan so
maybe quickly also again just for
exercise who knows what a query plan is
in here
oh okay nice so um the basic idea of a
query blend is that what it does it kind
of describes a step-by-step procedure
how this query is being executed for
example here you would see the tables on
the leaf of the query blend and then
there's operator that filters out only
the rows of the table for customers that
are in Europe and then the two tables
are joined this is a join operator which
brings these two tables together this
which is equivalent to this natural log
join statement here in in this part of
the query
so what database needs to do when it
comes up with a plan is so-called needs
to find a so-called good join order join
order means should I first join these
two tables customer and orders or the
order and order line table should be the
date should they be joined first because
depending on which tables We join first
the query might take might take a
seconds or hours to run this is a bit
the idea why we do join ordering in
database systems and the optimal join
order the better joint order depends or
database Optimum Optimizer selected
based on the so-called intermediate
result sizes of the H join let me
quickly show you what the intermediate
result size is for this query so for
this join order where we first join
customers and orders the first
intermediate result size after joining
customers with orders might be 5 million
and the final result might be 10 million
so this is a notion if you look at these
intermediate cardinalities how expensive
is this plan to to run in a database
system
now let's look at the second show in
order which is just these other joint
order where we first join orders with
products and then customers
and just because it uses different
filter predicates the first showing
result might be much smaller right so
the first here this show in the middle
result was 5 million here if we join
these two tables first the intermediate
result might be only one million while
the end result is clearly the same
because it's the same query it has the
same size at the end but the step to to
actually compute the query the first
step is much much cheaper to to run
so what databases need to reason about
is are these intermediate cardinalities
they need to find out what are these
cardinalities without actually running
the queries because they want to know if
I do it a query like in this order it's
much faster than the other order so they
need to come up with these estimates for
these for this inter for these
cardinalities before running the query
and with traditional methods in
databases this is often the problem why
databases don't provide a good
performance because databases don't come
up with the right estimate here they
misestimate the intermediate result size
and therefore they select the wrong plan
in your database system
so question is so what did what did what
did machine learning do here to solve
this problem and there was a paper in
2019 published by Andrea skip he
was at Theo Munich at the time and is
now working for Amazon redshift team
actually to bring these ideas into into
a cloud database system
um so he's been publishing a paper where
he showed that deep neural net Network
can actually better predict
cardinalities of query Blends than the
traditional methods and what they've
done is like let's say instantiation of
what I told you before of workload
driven learning they've been enumerating
different query plans so different join
orders they re so they looked at the
different intermediate cardinalities of
the different of the different possible
joints and use this to train a machine
learning model that can do cardinality
prediction so what you could do you
could feed in any types of join of your
database and ask this model what is the
expected uh cardinality so the result
size of the intermediate result when you
would join these two tables
and his paper they've shown that they
can significantly outperform classical
techniques so they compare to postgres
estimates which uses forms of histograms
or sampling they've also used other more
Advanced Techniques but but they've
shown that machine learning is much
better in finding the the intermittent
cardinalities in a highly accurate
manner
but again it comes at the downside that
I mentioned before right they needed to
run 10 000 queries for each database
they needed to repeat it repeat it
repeat the training data collection if
the data in your database changes
so for this we've been publishing a
paper in 2020 uh in realdb vldbu is one
of the flagship conferences in academic
and Industrial database research really
b stands for very large databases maybe
some of you know the conference here in
in this room
and the main idea is as I said we use
the idea of data-driven learning so we
learn a model not from queries and not
from query plans we learn it purely from
the data and in our paper we've we've
shown that with a new class of models
that are based on a category of models
called probabilistic circuits we can
define a new class of model called
relational some product networks don't
don't don't doesn't matter that much but
the idea is that these models learns the
data distribution within tables and
across tables to do cardinality
estimation
and what we actually do by looking at
this example which shows a database with
four tables we learn not just one
so-called relational sum product Network
per database but we learn in our sample
of rspns that allow us to do cardinality
prediction
and in fact what we do is if a query
comes in so let's say a query that joins
these three tables here we can still
combine different machine learning
models to estimate the cardinality for
join query that joins for example the
store table with the orders table with
the order line table
so how do these rspns look like and now
I'm this is where I'm really taking
maybe three more minutes to go in the
technical details and then I'm coming up
again uh to the uh to the uh to the more
high level ideas of machine learning
models for databases
so so what really relational some
products do they learn the structure of
a table let's now look just at one table
to make it simple and based on that they
can do better cardinality prediction I
just want to give you the intuition how
this learning procedure works
the learning procedure is based on two
steps you do row clusters you split your
tables into different disjoint sets of
rows that are similar and then you split
the columns apart if they are
statistically independent so what it
does it does this recursive procedure of
creating row clusters that are similar
and then trying to split columns apart
that are independent meaning that you
can do cardinality estimation in these
column sets independently
so what what it does actually it takes
here for example this table which has
only two columns and is a customer table
which has two attributes the customer
age and the customer region where the
customer is coming from so here it might
you see older European customers and
some older Asian customers but also
younger Asian customers and what it
should learn is the data distribution of
this table and what it's doing it's
first the first step in in these models
is splitting the the table into
so-called row clusters
which is shown here maybe 30 go in one
cluster and 70 go in the other cluster
then we test for each cluster if the
columns are independent if they are
independent we would split apart the
columns into disjoint branches into
product nodes of the of of our model and
in this case we would already terminate
and at the leaves of our model we would
store simple single dimensional
histograms
so in that sense this is very a very
simple model that we would learn but in
a very let's say in a more General
procedure such a model could be multiple
levels steep in fact it could be deep
model in with many many different layers
where we split columns and and rows
incrementally depending if for example
we find some independent columns or not
so this is a bit the idea I can I don't
want to go into into more details but at
the end what you what you see you learn
the data distribution of the whole table
in this in this tree structured model
here and how you can use that at runtime
is for example if a query like this
comes in and you want to find out how
many customers are from Europe and are
younger than 30. what you could do here
which would be maybe intermediate
cardinality for the join of these two
tables you could look at the at the leaf
level of your of your history of your of
your model find out that maybe in the
left Branch 80 are from Europe and 15
are younger than 13 in the right branch
of your tree ten percent are from Europe
and 20 are younger than uh than um than
30 years and then you would just because
uh we have an end operation here which
just multiply them together the
probabilities to come up with the
probabilities of customers from Europe
and customers that are younger than than
30 and then since they come from
different Road clusters you would just
add up the probabilities weighted by the
different cluster sizes and that the
engine would get the probability of how
many customers in the whole table are
from Europe and are younger than than
30.
and we've shown that this model is
highly accurate so in our vldb paper we
compared to this original approach from
Andrea skip that I mentioned as well as
to many other non-learned approaches
postgres estimates and other techniques
that have been used in databases or in
commercial database systems like Oracle
SQL server and so on and what you see
here is that the error of our
cardinality estimates are close to
Optimal in the median so Optimum means
here the Q error this so it's a relative
error how far are we off so a q error of
two means that we are our estimates are
two factor 2x off from the true
cardinalities so a factor of 1.3 means
that we are only 30 off on the average
case which is low compared to postgres
which is Factor seven of for example uh
in uh in in the median and in the max
case it's multiple orders of magnitude
of from the from the ground truth and we
are in the in the max error so the max
maximum cardinality estimation error
that our models make are much much
smaller than any of the other models
the good thing is and now I come maybe
also a bit too too uh the the questions
or um
uh what does this work have to do with
python clearly this is machine learning
right so we we've we've been developing
all our models with state-of-the-art
machine learning libraries and systems
and we open source our code and the nice
thing of open sourcing in Academia is
that this that our work has been now
reproduced in more than 100 other
academic papers and industries taking
already our source code and implements
it in commercial database systems which
is a academic person it's the thing you
are usually missing that people actually
use your your code and with open
sourcing yes it's true right so you
produce these high high so the these so
you work on on some really nice ideas
for many years and then the result is a
paper and with open sourcing code you
actually make it usable and this is what
I try to also push forward in my group
to our students to open source required
make it usable because then it might
just be used as a baseline in other
academic research papers which is
already good or it might be adopted by
by industry which is even nicer right
good
um I've seen our five minutes therefore
let me come up again from this from the
technical details of my work up to again
higher level of where is where are we
going with our research and here I want
to talk about clearly when I'm talk
about data learn databases 1.0 2.0 the
future has to be 3.0 it's not very
creative but it's it shows where we are
going
so what is what does learn database is
3.0 actually mean or for me what does it
mean this is a term that I'm using
personally so in learn database is one
dot zero and 2.0 the main goal of using
machine learning models to replace
classical database components was to
make databases faster or make them
reliably fast
um with learn database 3.0
we not just want to let's say take the
database as it is and just make it
faster but we want to make enhanced
databases make them smarter smarter by
using machine learning as a
inherent building block of of databases
to add new functionality so not just run
SQL queries over tables but do many more
things and recently my group has also
looked into the direction what many
people maybe do today but we've I think
we have our own our own unique twist to
it is the question can we kind of marry
what language models do with databases
and provide even smarter databases than
than we have already today
so what are databases used for today and
maybe so for everybody here in the room
it's clear they are made for managing
and querying tables right so you have
structured data and you can run SQL on
them with some extensions
for text some mild extensions for text
not really it's not text processing
there's some text search possible but
for now it's tables and SQL right that
you can do
what we do with this new direction of
learned databases 3.0 is as I said we
want to enhance databases in the real
world data is not always in tabular form
you have mixed modalities you have
tables but you also have like text and
images think of a medical database where
you have reports of doctors along with
the tables in your in your in your
databases as well as images that you
want to use maybe for Korean and our
high level Vision here is that we can
make these other modalities seamlessly
queryable without transforming them in
tables first and then maybe querying
them after we transform them in tables
but take them as is
and run a SQL query over such a
multimodal data set for example select
me the diagnosis of the patient
by joining the patients table with a
text collection where each maybe text
collection is so there's a report for
every patient in the database and we've
actually just submitted a new research
paperway shown where we can Implement
so-called multimodal join where we can
join tables and texts together and the
output of this join is again a table but
the user doesn't need to do anything
they can run just use the database with
text and tables using a SQL interface
and the output will always be a table
that comes back so the models actually
extract on-the-fly tables from text
another direction that is even more
exciting I think is
um
an observation that at the moment we can
only query the data in a database system
that we actually explicitly store in the
database right we first have to insert
it and only what we insert in a database
is queryable sounds normal but what it
means at the end is you are very much
limited to what you can get out of your
database you cannot just say this is
maybe representative set of data that I
gave you I want to query maybe just much
more information that I didn't give you
and therefore what we are currently
working on is a second project of one of
my PhD students what we call omniscient
databases so
databases that know what other databases
don't know that so the idea would be
here that we cannot only the query the
tables that are in a database system
that you explicitly stored but we can
query any other information that you
might be interested that is related to
the effects stored in the database for
example if you have movies you might be
interested in actors but you cannot
query them if you haven't right if you
haven't installed an active table in
your database you can only query movies
if you've inserted the movie's
information
but luckily also here language months
for example have a very huge body of uh
Common Sense knowledge that you can use
for querying and what we do here is
actually we use language models to
augment databases with virtual tables so
whatever is in your database would be
augmented by a language model and you
can query tables that are actually never
that you never thought in your database
you can run a query like this on your
database for example with a virtual join
you could join an actual table with a
non-existing table called actors that we
on the Fly extract from a language model
and with that I leave you here
I think it's interesting directions in
front of us especially if you think
about
creatively about how to combine these
two areas of machine learning not in
databases but for databases and I hope
that you kind of got an idea where
Academia is currently heading towards
together with industry because all of
the things that I at least showed in the
first part here is something that also
Cloud Industries thinking about
so with that thanks for your attention
and I'm happy to take questions
[Music]
thank you very much Carson for a very
interesting talk I was ordered to stand
here instead of there there's more light
so we have a number of questions that
are similar I'm going to start with the
the one that was uploaded the most are
the query results deterministic and
fully correct given that the nature of
ml models are probabilistic
so um the question is is uh are the
query results that we get out of machine
learning models deterministic and always
correct so the good thing is for many of
the tasks that I've shown you
correctness doesn't matter because the
internal database components that
already solve these tasks are not
accurate and correct anyways right so if
you think about a cardinality estimation
component in your database today
is already Incorrect and it's as I
showed you even more incorrect uh then
uh then the machine learning models we
are using so we are not making the world
worse by being maybe not as accurate and
therefore
um uh the the inner so being inaccurate
doesn't matter because at least in that
sense we are more accurate being
non-deterministic is actually a problem
because what it means if we maybe
retrain a model over overnight right the
cardinality is the estimation model is
retrained and tomorrow we have a new
cardinality estimation component what
means if we use this new model the query
plan might change and the query that
we've run yesterday might run completely
with a different runtime today because
now we choose a different plan
this is a problem because users don't
want to get at least slower queries from
day from one day one to the other right
but this is a problem that databases
today also have databases have something
like they run overnight a statistics run
that recollects uh for example
histograms of your data and based on
that they come up with a good query plan
and database today suffer already from
this problem of regressions and
therefore you do regression testing with
databases and this is what we do with
machine learning as well yes we had a
number of similar questions to this one
so I'm going to skip
and the next question
keeps changing just a little bit of
patience pick one
is it really a good idea to enrich your
database with a virtual drawing from a
Reddit fanfiction Forum oh that was a
funny one I like the idea so uh
I think maybe to come back to the
serious problems I think um everybody
knows so what the problems of language
models are and we're extracting virtual
tables from language models has its own
challenges one is hallucination right
this is a problem known for language
model it might come up with facts that
are not true the other problem is
language models have been trained on a
corpora and they only know the World
Knowledge up to a certain point right so
usually their knowledge ends at a point
in time you can't ask about recent
informational language models so it
would just if it was trained in 2022 it
the knowledge is based on the facts it
was trained on in 2022 so therefore
language models are being for example
there is a new class of language models
called retrieval augmented language
models that can read in documents and
extract new Knowledge from these
additional documents and
so for the problems that language models
have with extracting tables I think
there are interesting things for us to
tackle but there are solutions on the
horizon which makes it makes them
interesting also for databases
thank you the next question in database
3.0 will people need to learn SQL like
languages at all using llm we could just
use plain English right yeah so I
haven't been talking about that I've
been actually before language models
already been doing work on something
that is called natural language
interfaces for databases you can think
of it like a chat interface for your
database and this is clearly also one
thing you can do with your language
model so ask language model and this is
what language models can already do
today write in English sentence and ask
it to provide or to to create a SQL
query for your natural language
statement right so language models are
already good component if you want to
build a natural language interface or
chat interface for your database system
today and therefore yeah clearly so more
natural language and chat interfaces for
databases is something something highly
interesting as well
so now again another question related to
these are any of the RDA rdbms for
courses in parenthesis MySQL or postgres
already come with some ml features in
them
are there already ml features in the
famous popular
um depending on
um uh what you so if you um talk about
ml features in a way as I introduce them
so like uh let's say ml for autonomously
tuning databases or make or something
like a learned index there is clearly a
long history in databases to make them
self-tuning I haven't been talking about
this here in in this talk so self-tuning
databases have been so people have been
working on this already early on 90s in
the 2000s without machine learning and
companies like Microsoft and Oracle
already had Solutions and for example
Oracle has now a product called
autonomous database in the cloud so what
they've done they've taken their own
their existing world work on self-tuning
databases and added a bit of machine
learning at certain aspects to
automatically tune certain parameters of
your database system so there is to a
certain extent machine learning is
available in commercial databases at
least in the big commercial databases
I'm not sure about the open source
databases how far things are there so
okay
uh does any Cloud vendor currently
support any learned databases I think um
so I
um Cloud vendors uh are looking in the
opportunities of using machine learning
in a way that I described it here for
database systems uh I guess I mentioned
it
there are teams in these Cloud vendors
looking in these questions and some
features you can look it up I guess are
already available for example I know of
redshift it has a partitioning advisor
which is not really using deep learning
to solve the data database partitioning
problem to automatically partition the
database across multiple machines but
it's a form of automatic lightweight
machine learning that they use for this
coupled with some heuristics so there
are already Solutions in the cloud
databases where product teams are
working on and I think many more things
are going to come soon
so given it's around two and we have
many more questions and a lot of them
are similar to the ones that I've asked
I'm going to suggest that Carson will be
around for a bit longer so you can
personally ask your questions from
Carson
keynote talk and I will go yeah thank
you very much thanks again for being
here